[Music]
thank you very much for this opportunity
to speak and thank you to all of you for
coming here and let me go into
presentation mode all right so I guess
the first part of this is like you know
Who am I Kirt already told you I'm
Charlie's fronting there okay well who
is Charlie from their brief history my
path to Yale and I was born and raised
at Park Illinois which is just outside
of Chicago so that's the little oh I
didn't bring my laser pointer okay I'm
gonna do it without a laser pointer I'll
have to be very descriptive so they're
the blue and red dot that's the house I
grew up in and I went to Oak Park and
River Forest High School now for you
kids out there the inspiration why am I
here in front of you right now and it
comes down to two people doc Davison he
was my chemistry teacher sophomore year
and then mr. mayor he was my physics
teacher jr. and they I mean they didn't
pay special attention to me or anything
like that but they just transformed my
my view of science and I've always liked
math but I could I couldn't remember my
mathematics teacher name I hope he's not
mad oh yeah all right okay so then there
was this junior engineering technical
side II which I don't think exists
anymore but I was part of it and then
when I was a sophomore it's hard to read
so University of Illinois at Chicago
summer program engineering elect the
electronic calculator contest so this
isn't about you know 78 79 when
electronic calculators had just come out
so we had a contest and I won
all right first place
so yeah it was back that at TI 30 which
which revolutionized education if you
ask me now they have a lot of 80 or
something TI 425 okay
so then when I went I went to college
University of Illinois urbana-champaign
but I did take a one semester off in
France study abroad I highly recommend
it to anybody it's it changes your view
of your own country and the world so
there I am yeah look young doe name mm
okay so then I got I got my BS in
chemistry in 85 then where did I go oh I
went to Berkeley oh thank you so yeah so
so I went to Berkeley for graduate
school and Here I am in in the lab this
is so completely dangerous there's like
lasers at eye level right now I am
wearing goggles of course but but but
and we knew it was dangerous but we had
to do it just because of the
configuration of the of the instrument
and everything like that so you know
there's there's weather there's ways to
mitigate risk and we we managed oh yeah
right so my group we would go skiing
Lake Tahoe every once in a while this is
when I can catch some air I don't catch
air anymore it's a very dangerous yeah
we're talking about danger so I don't do
that anymore
okay so then I got my PhD 1991 and then
I went to the University of Rochester in
upstate New York hmm so that's right
over there and I spent a few years there
finished up in 1994 and then I began
here at Yale at that time and here
there's a little dot okay in case in
case you're wondering where New Haven
it's right there and this is my lab I
think I might show this again later on
but I do experimental physical chemistry
so it's a lot of lasers it's not test
tubes and beakers and Bunsen burners
it's basically lasers and laser tables
and a lot of mirrors all right at the
end okay actually Jake do you happen to
have that piece of paper with the timing
yeah all right thank you
how we doing Oh perfect okay so I would
like to now start describing my research
and it's gonna be in a variety of levels
from very broad not even my own right
most of it's not my own research but
from some very broad ideas oh we don't
need there we go
all right I want your full attention
okay so yeah so so I've been doing
research and number of areas for a
number of years let me first introduce
the members of my research group because
often when I get to the end of the talk
I don't have time to do so
so the current people are shown here
John's work
Kevin Regan who's right there Colleen I
don't think Colleen is here that's me
Jake who's gonna be like helping a lot
so you're gonna see a bunch of actually
have you ever been coming to these
events the the 10 o'clock thing the
hands-on stuff because Jake does that so
have you ever come to this before a
couple times all right
do you recognize Jake stand up Jake so
they can see if they recognize you all
right all right all right and then as we
go down the line oh that's yen's no I
don't think he's here he's German he's a
great guy and then I also work out on
West Campus you may or may not have
heard about West Campus it used to be
bear and there's a bunch of people out
there and what I'm gonna be talking
about today is mostly centered on the
work that I do at West Campus renewable
energy and artificial photosynthesis so
it's a collaboration of for Bob Crabtree
Gary Brad Vig Victor Batista and myself
and we all bring different viewpoints
into studying this problem Bob Crabtree
is a world-famous
inorganic chemist has a textbook Gary
bread big is a world-famous person who
studies photosynthesis and something
called the oxygen-evolving complex which
we won't get into Victor Pete Batista is
a world-famous theoretician and
computational chemist and then he got me
doing doing experimental physical
chemistry all right and then that's
that's the website I hope it's
up-to-date yeah kevin says mostly okay
all right so this is what I want to talk
about and you can see ok outline
starting with the importance of basic
science I I think everybody in this room
understands the importance of basic
science
I'm not saying basic science is better
than applied or manufacturing everybody
has to do their job but there is there
is a need for basic science and the
funding agencies have to recognize that
which unfortunately as the years go on
they don't as much as they should and
then I'll move so that that's very
global very very broad observations then
we're gonna I will talk about the idea
of renewable energy that won't take so
long
basically we need to get away from
carbon-based fuels and then I'll kind of
start to motivate my own research talk
about artificial photosynthesis so as
the name implies it's kind of like
photosynthesis but it's not exactly so
I'll talk about the head he must be very
happy
yeah and then then I'll talk about
spectroscopy and I think you've heard
about spectroscopy in the past in this
particular series of lectures I see
professor Vaquero up there
and he did some nice spectroscopy
demonstrations so I won't be able to
reproduce that but I'll at least
introduce you to it and then this idea
of conductivity conductivity is really
important for the type of work that I do
to contribute to the collaboration on
our official photosynthesis so let's get
there when we get there so so basically
this broad very super broad kind of
broad still a bit broad getting a little
bit more narrow somewhat more narrow and
then like really really narrow all right
start at the top here we go the
importance the importance of basic
science research let's think about it
the laser light amplification by
stimulated emission of radiation one
right here you use one every time in the
grocery store you use one and this came
out in the late 50s it was developed and
here's a lab notebook page from Gordon
Gould and you know the the funding for
this was just like oh this is
interesting they used to have the maser
the microwave amplification blah blah
and let's push it into the optical
region of the spectrum and you know
nobody knew that there was gonna be
laser pointers and department store
scanners another one magnetic resonance
imaging MRI so this is based on
something called nuclear magnetic
resonance and I don't know if professor
zoom happens to be here at this very
moment apparently not but he's an NMR
guy but to make it more palatable to the
general public they wanted to get
nuclear out of the name alright but but
also it is more descriptive to talk
about magnetic resonance imaging and I
think everyone's familiar with that so
NMR itself was first discovered in what
38 and then followed up in 46 and here
is like one of the original figures
this is from blocks paper in 46 original
figures of the like the absorption of
water as a functional magnetic field in
the depth region of the spectrum okay
now fast-forward you know whatever 46 I
don't know about 50 years or thereabouts
and now way of this we we have MRI
imaging it's an amazing tool that
doctors can use and it's all completely
based you know it
what bit this would not have existed if
it wasn't for the basic science that
that established the fact that you can
change the resonant absorption
frequencies of molecules when you apply
a magnetic field alright last one last
one this is gonna be quick last one is
is the global positioning system so we
all have that right we we carry around
our phones you know so we may or may not
be broadcasting our position depending
on our security settings but so this is
base that the the fact that this works
is based on special relativity and
general relativity so according to the
special relativity 1905 this is Einstein
do you think Einstein really was
thinking about cellphones when he was
doing this I don't think so okay so that
turns out that when you're moving really
fast clocks tick slightly slower when
you're in Earth orbit that's only about
18,000 what is it miles per I can't
remember 18,000 miles per second I think
it is anyway you're not moving that
close to speed of light but anyway your
clocks tick a little bit slower on the
other hand when you are above the
surface of the earth gravity is a bit
smaller and then actually clocks tick a
bit faster alright so this is this is
general relativity alright so you put
the two of them together and it turns
out you know 45 minus 7 equals 38 and in
order to know your location on the earth
earth you need time accuracy of a few
nanoseconds so it takes for light to go
this far one foot or 30 centimeters it
takes about a nanosecond so you know
that this far takes about five
nanoseconds so when you pull up your
device and you want to see where you are
it's gonna be limited by the accuracy of
the clocks from the satellites so anyway
if you did not if you did not account
for that you would soon your your device
would soon not know where you are and
there we go alright there's there's my
device Samsung I don't know if I dare
say this I'm not an eye person I don't
like eye stuff okay but you're okay if
you're an eye person kevin is it's okay
I accept your decision but I disagree
with it okay
need for renewable energy yeah okay so
here here we go this is this this little
this list was compiled by Richard
Smalley won the Nobel Prize and about I
don't know 2008 or something like that
or maybe even before this unfortunately
he passed away but but but he did make
this list and there's a bunch of really
important stuff on this list energy
water I mean you gotta have drinkable
clean water you have to have food and
then there's the environment poverty and
then war and all this stuff these are
all problems but if you ask me and I
think if you were to ask Rick Smalley if
we have abundant energy then a lot of
these problems go away not not all but a
lot for example water if we have really
inexpensive energy you can desalinate
water if you have really if you have
carbon free energy the environment is
gonna be better you know you're never
gonna stop terrorism and war so maybe we
should take that off the list that
that's a human that's a human thing okay
the United States
and the breakdown of energy sources and
it's mostly carbon-based yeah we have
petroleum natural gas I think that says
oil but I can't really tell
nuclear I used to be very anti-nuclear
but I'm not anymore
just so you know there's there is the
problem of the the waste if we could get
rid of that we'd be okay but it's not
carbon emitting so I think there's
promise there and then there's renewable
energy so if you blow up the renewable
energy part of the pie then you see
there's a breakdown mostly hydroelectric
but also other stuff and then there we
go solar fuels which is which is my
thing
so renewable energy 10% solar fuels is
6% of the 10% and that leaves you at
0.6% overall it's been growing
dramatically over the last number of
years but it's still it's still
reasonably a small contribution okay so
the real real real reason that we need
renewable energy is to have carbon free
energy in the old days people will talk
about you know oil is running out which
sort of is but coal is not and we seem
to have plenty of natural gas so you
really cannot make an argument for
renewable energy based on dwindling
resources of carbon-based fuels but you
can make the argument based on carbon
dioxide right it's a greenhouse gas this
is this is from this the so-called
Keeling curve do I have that on there no
I don't this is the so-called Keeling
curve you get these annual variations
during spring and summer so that's why
it oscillate up and down whenever you
know trees are bringing co2 in or
releasing it and then the black line is
sort of the average and it has gone up
I can't remember what it was in 1850 but
after the Industrial Revolution there's
been this huge increase in well of
course fossil fuel burning and
consumption and therefore carbon dioxide
emission I I don't have the formula but
basically when you burn a hydrocarbon
you combine the hydrocarbon with oxygen
to make water and co2 and the co2 has
gone up dramatically and it's a
greenhouse gas so it's it's it's causing
the planet to warm and there's you know
don't think about people who deny it
cuz there's for every one person who
denies this has happened there are
people out there who do for every one
person who denies it there's five
hundred who support it okay so if we
were to give equal time to both sides of
the issue
you would hear every day for two years
from someone who says this is happening
and for one day every two years you
would hear from someone who's not
alright
so equal equal reporting does not mean
50/50 huh oh boy I'm getting worked up
alright so yeah there's this thing
called the tipping point and various
climate scientists felt feel that if you
go over 400 ppm that's you know you have
these feedback loops and then it'll get
really warm okay clearly it is above 400
and you know gosh the the the sky has
not fallen thankfully but give it you
know give it a few more years this this
is gonna be an interesting ride I'm
looking forward to it okay and there's a
temperature temperature's going a hockey
stick graph maybe you've heard about
that maybe you haven't
oh yeah Mike all right okay so this
person Michael Mann was sort of the
first one so co2 is one thing
temperature is another thing and Michael
Mann worked on getting the word out that
temperatures are actually rising I mean
it's it's it's not huge from here to
here is about point eight degrees C
which is one point four Fahrenheit you
might think oh nice you know I want it
to shovel as much
but it there's major problems for you
know plants and animals and sea level oh
yeah do I have that yeah so Arctic ice
will melt faster and oh shoot okay and
then not only will the Arctic ice melt
which puts water into the oceans but
when the temperature of the oceans
increase you know water expands as it
gets hotter and that's actually going to
be a larger contribution to issues and
then finally getting back to Michael man
he was just skewered by various think
tanks and climate deniers and people
like that I don't know that he's still
working for the government anymore I
mean he was not allowed to go give talks
on any of this stuff and it's a common
theme when various large institutions
are trying to suppress something like
like that smoking causes cancer I mean
does anybody here believe that smoking
does not cause cancer anyone anyone all
right well if I asked that question in
1958 about half of you would say no it
does not but now we know that it does
and there was this huge push to suppress
that and we're seeing the same thing
with climate change and global warming
okay well enough depression for for a
while let me let me talk about
artificial photosynthesis and now I'm
getting again I started really broad and
getting closer and closer and closer to
the research that I do so artificial
photosynthesis well alright so you have
you know like all the plants outside and
around us they take sunlight and there's
a leaf that has this very complicated
mechanism and then they take co2 and
water co2 from the air water from the
rain
and then it converts it into oxygen
which is good for us because we breathe
oxygen and then sugars which then
triggers themselves can be burned but a
plant will then convert them into other
things like wood or something okay
so that's that's the inspiration
super-complicated oh okay
I want to got it alright so then in the
collaboration that I mentioned early on
with the West well better with their
chemistry people but a lot of the effort
is out of West Campus what we want to do
is is is simulate in a very technical
fashion the process of photosynthesis
and our our goal is actually to do this
thing called the water oxidation
reaction there's two steps in
photosynthesis one step is to oxidize
water and get the electrons these
electrons are so important because that
is what reduces something to make a fuel
so you have to have both but our
collaboration is all about the water
oxidation and we want to have a catalyst
and then the catalyst itself does not
absorb in the visible region of the
spectrum so we need a linker molecule a
strong dye a chromophore that absorbs
quite quite a lot and then that all has
to be anchored onto a nanoparticle
surface the reason we have to use
nanoparticles is because they have a
very very very high surface area right
like you know one gram 1 gram of
nanoparticles which is just a little bit
like that would have 50 square meters of
surface area all right okay this is a
little bit closer natural photosynthesis
it works for sure and then this is the
the we call it bio-inspired it's not
biomimetic biomimetic would be that
we're trying to mimic biology and you
know create some sort of a membrane
protein thing
we're not doing that we are inspired by
the fact that this can be done right we
know that it can be done
oh all right well I was supposed to have
hear that it works but it's super
complicated and then hear that
unfortunately at this point in time it
doesn't really work we're getting there
we're getting there
it sort of works but it's very simple
and this gives us hope that we will be
able to outdo nature alright so on more
than one occasion people have come up to
me or seminar speakers when we go out to
dinner or something like that they say
to me well how can you ever outdo nature
right nature's been doing photosynthesis
for three billion years right so how you
gonna do better well keep in mind that
natural photosynthesis evolved for the
plants to stay alive it can be in you
know drought conditions it can be in
super rainy conditions it can be in any
kind of conditions that you can imagine
the whole idea of evolution is that the
plant stays alive the plants are not
here to grow a lot of wood for us to
burn and use as energy okay so I like to
make this analogy between airplanes and
birds so at the mid to late 1800s people
wanted to fly you see birds flying they
do it pretty easily and they zip around
and they're birds so some of the early
attempts at flight mimicked birds right
you had these flapping wings and of
course you've probably seen videos of
this you know they don't they don't go
anywhere yeah this is interesting so
again flapping wings because birds have
wings that flap so why not so this guy
yeah it was called in a roof rope
powered by a steam engine it's like
what's the heaviest thing in the world
you could think of it
see imagine so unfortunately it did not
fly oh damn
alright so then Kitty Hawk I don't know
if any of you have ever been to Kitty
Hawk but we went there once and it was a
fast and is it there's a natural world
and national it's a national park and
heard a great lecture this is not I
could just got this off the internet but
but the idea was that they showed that
you could have powered flight and that
was revolutionary right there's a 1903
people who didn't do the the bird
flapping stuff for a long time people
have been doing gliders for a long time
but they were able to show that you
could have sustained flight and there
was two enabling technologies one was
the internal combustion engine I'm sure
you've heard about them you know the
bicycle shop in Ohio and then they would
tinker on the engine but the internal
combustion engine was able to provide
enough power compared to its mass that
it actually would allow you to fly and
the other thing is mastering yaw and
this is what I learned on the from the
from the park ranger at the at the
National Park there in Kitty Hawk so
does anybody know what yah is that y'all
its yah anybody anybody anybody looks
like that guy knows ok so think about a
plane so this is a plane airplane and
there's three degrees of freedom well
there's of course XY and Z its position
in space but then there's three
rotational degrees of freedom so if
you're going up that and down that's the
pitch if you're going this way and that
way
that's the roll and if you're kind of
scooting around this way in that way
that's the yaw and that was the one that
nobody could figure out how to make
stable so they would be flying these
planes and then they would go like that
and then there's go out of control so
that was that was critical for human
flight all right so then we got this I'm
showing I I like to show Argentinean
airlines because my collaborator Victor
Bautista who I mentioned earlier is from
Argentina but the real point is
if you want to go to Argentina will you
take a jet plane or will you be a bird
if you're a bird it's gonna take a
couple of months if you're on a big 747
or whatever it's gonna take you I don't
know what it takes you know seven hours
or something like that so yes planes are
not as maneuverable as Birds fine but if
you if your goal is to go 3,000 miles or
whatever then you're better off on a
plane than being a bird so that's what's
inspiring us that we can actually do
better than photosynthesis with our
artificial photosynthesis
all right spectroscopy okay
so now we need to show the spectroscopy
demo see how this works I have a number
of demos some might not work you know
that's the way life goes okay so yeah
maybe Jake can help me we have a variety
of laser goggles you know when we when
we work in the lab we always wear laser
goggles some block certain frequency in
the wavelengths and some black others
you can see this one that's clearly blue
and the other ones look reasonably
similar let me let me go back to the
white right right right right so we can
hold them up
yeah I actually had already done this
but I don't know where it is okay so
what Jake and I will do here is hold up
a variety yeah I know it's kind of small
but there's gonna be other things that
are that are larger so here if you just
look at these three they they they all
look pretty similar but you can see that
there are differences in the amount of
light transmitted and then the blue one
is very different all right okay so
that's a very qualitative way of
thinking about color and this topic of
spectroscopy is to motivate how you can
learn about different materials based on
the colors that they're absorbing all
right all right okay so the next thing I
do need the black screen okay so the
next thing is to use the flashlight here
we go
all right so I got this flashlight thing
and you can focus it so this is
something called a diffraction grading
and oh we should Trump okay Kevin hit
the Lights man yeah you know okay
so that's you know the rainbow the
visible region of the spectrum so yeah
yeah Jake I think oh sorry yeah yeah
okay here we go okay
all right so why don't you put in some
different laser goggles okay I'll try to
hold still
all right see that one that that
completely cuts out the blue all right
[Music]
all right see look at that one it cuts
out the red those must be the blue ones
nah I'm having a hard time holding it
here okay well shoot all right that's
what it was also crystal blue okay so so
the idea is all right lights thank you
unfortunately now all the lights come on
so I need to dim the ones in the front
so you can actually see what I'm trying
to project okay so what I'm showing now
here it's the same you know a set of
goggles you'll see a few of the a few of
these different goggles and we're going
to see how much transmission there is as
a function of wavelength so we go from
red to violet so yeah I'm sure a lot of
you have heard of ROYGBIV red orange
yellow green blue indigo violet so
that's worth knowing
yeah when you go to longer wavelengths
or lower frequencies than the red you
get into the infrared and when you go to
higher frequencies or shorter wavelength
than violet you get into the ultraviolet
and I would guess that everybody here
has heard of all of those so we can
quantify okay Jake and I just showed you
putting the different goggles in there
it did this it did that it did whatever
but here you can have a spectrometer
that will tell you exactly how
transmission there is at the different
wavelengths so that was one all right
yeah so then what I did here okay so
here here's the entire here's the entire
visible spectrum and then what I've done
here is sort of just delineated which
wavelengths would get through each of
these pairs of goggles so that's one the
blue ones yeah okay so the blue ones
allow to let a lot of blue through as
you might imagine but there's red in
there that you would not have noticed
when we did the thing where we projected
it on the screen these are basically
transmitting from the green into the red
but they're highly absorbing or blocking
at the blue side of the spectrum and
then oh yeah right so the thing to show
is that these two when you look at them
in a picture they look reasonably
similar obviously this one's darker but
then when you look at the spectrum this
is the spectrum the transmission
spectrum of this one where it transmits
everything from about 550 nanometers out
into the red whereas this one transmits
a much smaller region of the spectrum so
this is what spectroscopy is all about
spectroscopy is about quantifying the
amount of transmission or absorption you
know they're related to each other high
transmission means small absorption low
transmission means high absorption so
they're basically two different ways to
think about the same thing but
spectroscopy is all about quantifying
quantifying things both in terms of
wavelength and in terms of overall
transmission
okay now time-resolved spectroscopy now
we're getting closer we're getting
closer to what I do so I think oh yeah
right so here we go I was on a boat once
and I used this is back when I had a
camera where I could actually change the
shutter speed mine
my smartphone is not smart enough for me
to change the shutter speed but if you
have a very long shutter speed then
everything's kind of blurred out but if
you have a fast shutter speed everything
is very crisp and clear right blurry
crisp so the idea is that the faster the
faster you acquire information the
faster your shutter in this case is the
more time resolution you will have time
resolution so things are moving so as a
function of time they get blurry and
here you capture them in a much shorter
amount of time
and they're nice and crisp okay well
given given given given the time
constraints here let me let me okay
really quick really quick 1872 this is
just half the camera came out the camera
was first developed at around about 1850
1855 something like that so this guy boy
bridge was an early adopter and there
was a huge debate in 1872 when a horse
is galloping does it ever have all four
of its hooves off the ground that was
the debate and a lot of said a lot of
people said didn't lobules it so then
Stanford Leyland Stanford you might have
heard of Stanford University and he was
also governor in California that guy he
put up $42,000 to settle this question
so Muybridge came in and set up twelve
cameras this is not a movie even though
it looks you know the website made it
look like a movie but it was 12 separate
cameras as the horse galloped along and
then you see right there that it has all
four hose off the ground at the same
time so at that point you know there's
no need there's no need to debate it
anymore
it's true it's true that when a horse is
galloping there's there are moments
where all four hooves are off the side
off the ground at the same time so then
the last thing on this one is $42,000
146 years ago that would be equivalent
of three million dollars it's not cheap
but you know Bill and Bill and Melinda
Gates will fund research at this sort of
level so it's it's not outrageous Oh
hey demo time rubber bands rubber bands
now you only need one rubber band for
every other person there's gonna be a
team this is a team event so two people
two people one rubber band okay so what
you need to do unfortunately I don't
have one do you have one ah thank you
this is Denzel my grandson
okay so what what we'll do you'll take
turns one of you will stretch it out and
the other one using two fingers you want
to imitate you want to imitate what's on
the screen there two fingers kind of
winged it and then observe the shape of
the rubber band so here we go right one
more time two fingers and keep your eye
on it it happens really fast really fast
and then take turns so you can hold it
and then here Jake can hold it and I'll
bring it
[Music]
you have to look really closely it
happens so fast it happened so fast
so look very closely
all right so does anybody want to
describe what the shape of the
rubberband looks like as after you
release it yeah I can't hear you what
ribbon oh yeah yeah yeah you're
absolutely right
okay so let me show you this is done
with high speed photography just a fast
camera and this these pictures were
actually taken by a high school student
so those of you who are in or near high
school this is something you might want
to try at some point so there it is
before releasing it and then after
releasing it it does yes you're right it
does start to look like an oval but
surprisingly it still maintains a little
bit of the shape that it had before you
released it right it's not a perfect
oval just yet and that's the thing that
your eye just can't pick up and then it
flips back down that's the red one you
can still see a little bit of structure
in the shape of the rubber band as it
boils down but finally the green one the
green one is when it goes back up and
now it's quite smooth so the point of
that was to demonstrate that things
happen faster then you can perceive with
your eyes and therefore you have to come
up with experiments that will give you
allow you to gather information on a
much faster time scale no that's it
okay so here Edgerton he was at MIT in
the 40s so what he did instead of using
a camera that had fast you know shutter
speeds he would use a strobe light so he
would have a camera where the shutter
was open all the time and he would put
this person into a darkroom
so it wouldn't expose the film and then
as the person started their golf swing
it would trigger the strobe light to
therefore actually I guess it would go
this way therefore give you an image
where the golf club was every you know a
few maybe 200 microseconds or 10
microseconds so to get to shorter time
scales you can't use shutter speeds you
have to use pulses pulses of light
strobe lights all right now we have a
demo okay so Jake here has a strobe
light yeah it's too bright okay maybe I
should stand here all right here we go
it's too bright maybe actually if you
just go back a little bit so we're away
from over here all right let's try it
out again okay so that's a slow shutter
speed the repetition rate now when it's
a faster repetition rate you get more
information you get more information
about the position of the object all
right Kevin
and I I knew that that would not be very
impressive I think well you know I
should have danced around that's that's
what I like to do when there's strobe
lights going on but Jake made a really
nice sort of animation there we go about
this
okay so this animation depicts something
happening at different strobe light
repetition rate we're gonna start slow
and then go medium and then go fast
so if you have a very slow repetition
rate here's what you might see okay so
what did that look like you're too far
ahead of me nobody nobody heard that it
looked it it looked like a ball going
back and forth and did it not damn
alright so if we do a little bit faster
then you get more information because
you don't just see that the two extremes
but you see there's something going on
in the middle and then you speed up the
flash rate a little bit more and now yes
yes you see that it's a pendulum and
finally there's a little animation I owe
a great thanks to Jake or putting this
together
[Applause]
alright ok so let's see I've got well 15
minutes
oops I know everyone's super busy my
goal was to finish up five minutes
before noon I'll try to do that but it
might be noon ok so I sort of mentioned
before that in my letter maybe I even
showed you this but in my lab I'm in the
chemistry department obviously and well
maybe it's not obvious but my office is
just on the hall but I don't mix things
together with beakers and test tubes not
that there's anything wrong with doing
that we need people who do that but in
my lab it's lasers and mirrors and metal
tables and somewhere you know buried in
here is a little cuvette or a little
sample that word that we're doing some
sort of spectroscopy on just to get
oriented I know this is a little much
but but basically when you think about
time you go down in factors of three
orders of magnitude so we all know what
a second is right tick tock a
millisecond is a thousand times slower
and and that's actually a bit faster
than like if you wanted to hit like your
stopwatch on your phone two times in a
row you wouldn't be able to do it in a
millisecond and more like 30
milliseconds and then you go to a
microsecond so it's a million times
shorter than a second nanosecond is a
billion time shorter picosecond is a
trillion time shorter and then a
femtosecond it's actually a quadrillion
times I you just you just can't imagine
how short these types are yet so there's
a very short times but they're actually
very important so there's a couple thing
and there's many things I'm sure but in
regard to the photosynthesis stuff
there's this really important
step in photosynthesis that occurs in
three picoseconds and then also envision
when photons come into your eye they
excite they excite retinol and it
undergoes and I and I a shape change and
isomerization that happens in three
hundred three hundred femtoseconds and
then you know that that cascades to
triggering various nerves I don't know I
don't think about biology but at some
point at some point you get it you get a
signal in your brain from the light
hitting your eye but the whole thing the
whole thing happens in three hundred
femtoseconds okay so yeah so what we do
when we're doing time-resolved
spectroscopy is were take pictures of a
system after perturbing it now the
pictures are not like photos they're not
like the animation I showed of the
pendulum they're not actual photos but
instead what we do is we measure the
spectrum after photo exciting the
material so yeah here here here might be
the absorption spectrum this is the blue
goggles prior to photo excitation and
then after photo excitation let time go
on I'm and I'm not saying blue goggles
are gonna turn into orange goggles but
if you're looking at a molecular system
the absorption spectrum can drink can
change dramatically from when you photo
excite the material until you probe and
measure the absorption spectrum so
that's the general that's general idea I
can skip delay lines so it takes light
one nanosecond to go this far so you do
this deal where you split the light into
two paths one path is fixed one path is
on a movable mirror if you make the
mirror move farther and farther apart
then the arrival time of the pulse here
pulse B occurs later and later and later
okay so conductivity so the type of work
that I do involves conductivity of
electrons in a variety of semiconductors
so there's the Dru de model don't worry
I'm not I'm not not gonna torture you so
the big deal here is that Sigma is the
conductivity and in my group though we
go beyond the drew to model and there's
the drew dismiss now and sometimes even
that is not enough soho then we use the
extended drew dismiss model with this
additional ink evans an expert on that
so yeah don't worry about it here we go
mm-hm hmm alright yeah no need no need
to worry about it this is the important
stuff that conductivity is equal to the
product of mobility and concentration
and we're gonna demonstrate this Jake is
going to demonstrate this with salt
solutions even though when we do our
measurements its electrons charge
particles are charged particles so
before we get started let me just show
you if you have a low concentration then
you'll have some some amount of
conductivity if you have a high
concentration you have a lot more ions
so you're gonna have a lot higher
conductivity similarly that that's one
term that's the concentration term the
other term is the mobility how easy it
is for the ions to move through the
solution so if you have very small ions
the fact is that they've had to move
very slowly whereas if you have large
ions they move much easier so we're
gonna show some salt solutions sodium
chloride lithium chloride potassium
chloride and you'll be able to see the
differences all right yes show kind of
QB demos that's where we are okay Jake
okay all right I'll be the announcer so
I mean here's my assistant
Jacobs B's okay so what we have here oh
we were gonna do the document camera
right okay
well hopefully you can see it's these
it's these two metal these two metal
electrodes that we're putting into a
beaker and we're gonna do water we're
gonna do salt solutions and then we have
a lightbulb here and the higher the
conductivity either due to mobility or
concentration the higher the
conductivity the brighter the light bulb
will shine okay all right so what do we
have here pure water nothing all right
like out of the faucet okay no kind of
could be no conductivity because there's
nothing in it so we've seen no light
then we add a little bit of salt
ooh look at Oh lights all right a little
bit of salt a little bit brighter a
little bit of light we add a little bit
more salt so we're increasing the
concentration right this is kind of this
is all sodium chloride so it's the same
ions it's just a higher concentration
and as you see it gets brighter
when you have more a higher
concentration all right yeah there you
go
there you go okay so that's to
demonstrate how the concentration of the
ions affects you know higher
concentration is higher conductivity now
we're going to do or Jake is going to do
a little demonstration about the
mobility so there's two solutions here
there's a lithium chloride solution and
there's a potassium chloride solution so
the chloride ions and negative ions are
the same the only difference is that one
of them has lithium positive ions and
the other one has potassium positive
ions and they have different mobilities
the concentration is exactly the same
all right so that's the potassium
reasonably high conductive not quite as
bright as what you saw before that's
because it's a lower concentration so
you can definitely look we can go back
and forth a couple of times so we got
lithium and then potassium and then
lithium and then potassium so all right
you know your lights please so which one
has higher mobility lithium or potassium
yes that's right potassium because
that's when the light was brightest
likes
I okay I think what we need to do is the
iodine clock reaction which I actually
skipped over
okay so here's gonna be another example
I know it's almost noon so don't worry
here's gonna this is another example of
how reactions happen really fast and can
be very difficult and can be very
difficult to observe with your with your
own eyes woops
okay so jake has a beaker here with a
stir unfortunately the auto contrast is
a little bit difficult to see but he's
gonna mix two solutions together it's
called the iodine clock reaction and it
has the property that it starts out
clear and then becomes deep deep deep
blue within within a fraction of a
second so it might be better yeah it
might be better to turn that off if you
can see all right oh I see okay yeah the
lights didn't help oh that was a bad
transition but luckily we're right we
have more the idea was that it happened
really fast
so now Jake will we'll do it another
time I guess we'll just have to leave
the lights on keep your eye on it and I
want you to be able to describe what the
process was as the color change occurred
get clear clear clear clear clear clear
clear clear Oh blue and that happened
really fast so I have a little video
here of the iodine clock reaction you
need to have the need to have the audio
for this guy so he's a professor at
University of Nottingham he's very
interesting okay oh now we're not
hearing anything well that's no good
yeah oh well it's Waco's so oh and I'm
not even showing it maybe that's the
problem
[Music]
okay so here we go this is what you just
saw all right so then if i zoom forward
he did it in like super slow motion yes
I need to do
yeah hey you do the birthday parties
can't do that anymore
alright so now there's gonna be a
slow-motion her
fear in order to have I treat - in your
solution you have to have 12 I - I
didn't and I have died which is I - and
these can interact together by 3 - so if
you have ice cream - in the solution we
get nothing I chose a Gomory different
like that we've done it I own three -
plus they react together so that the
actor reacts with the iodide to make the
solution
okay well but before that me let me just
go back quickly show you this magic says
that parties pretending it was a
conjurer the magic words
now I'll see the slo-mo of the solo
version yes I used to do chemical
capturing Reverend away
- an area it interacts and even a low
concentration will be due very intense
color
[Music]
so you can see that it happens
throughout the solution be ready to
catch that but but there were these
little spots there were these little
spots where the blue color started to
form and they were everywhere within the
beaker it's not like I went from the top
to the bottom or anything like that and
that's the kind of thing that when we
just did the reaction here that you
could not perceive with your own eyes
given the time yeah - you're a great
disappointment I'm sure I'm not going to
be able to tell you about conductivity
and terrors transmission spectra
basically what this section was was to
bring everything together to talk about
fast you know flashes of light to get
information on short timescales and then
conductivity because that's what we do
we when you have high conductivity the
transmission of the light that we use is
very low and then we can quantify on a
picosecond time scale so it's really
short Pico seconds so because again time
scale we can quantify how rapid and how
efficient the photo excitation is so you
know you can come and visit me at some
point you know I'll tell you all about
it but otherwise I'm done
[Applause]
[Music]